alice a beaucoup qui est stop à
l'islamophobie et à l'islamophobie et
reste à la justice un pays fait face
justice fait pas justice nous
indiqueront comment et justice très bon
du livre vient islamo copier travail
c'est ici votre unique ou celle qui a
quitté la coordination n'est pas son
opposition résolue à la loi et à ses
futurs conséquence les bases et leurs
différences de cette politique quoique
catherine futile nous notifier par les
mots codés par morne et puis il y avait
ces histoires de chiens de refaire de la
mythologie grecque qui surveille le
faisons que sans actes la politique
comme la foi ne valent rien alors il y
avait des gens qui je ne voudrais pas
qu'on vit
[Musique]